[Music]
this is a time of year when many of us
make new year's resolution including
setting new goals for our health yep
we've all doing that james corden began
that journey last new year's when he
started working for wwe as a paid
ambassador now he shared why he needed
to make a change in his life
i've realized
that every year for the past decade
probably even 15 years
on january 1st
i've told myself and anyone that would
listen that this is it this is the year
i'm going on a diet i'm going to lose a
load of weight
i'm fed up with the way i look i'm fed
up with being unhealthy and this is it
this is the year i'm doing it and
because of that
i've
over christmas
eaten everything that's in the fridge
because in my head in january i'm
starting this diet and it'll be a
success and
as you can see well it hasn't
the late late show host calls the
experience transformative in the past
year he's lost lost listen to this
number 28 pounds that's fantastic news
first on cbs mornings we're very excited
to welcome james corden to the show good
morning to you james happy new year and
well done
well done happy new year to you
happy new year listen i'm sitting here
after christmas break i said yesterday
elastic is my new friend because i ate
every damn thing that you can dream of
so i need to get back on the program and
you know that experience you've talked
about it why did it work this time for
you
well i don't know that it's as simple as
saying that it worked it's that it's
working
and that's
i think the
biggest thing that i've realized this
past 12 months moving forward is
it's like oh you can't
go on a diet
that's not what it's about you've got to
sort of separate
health and weight loss in a way and go
this isn't something because if you go
on a diet you've got the there's the
very notion of going well then one day i
will come off this diet and it's not
about that it's about
not starving yourself of anything and
i've done every
i mean i've done every diet under the
sun gail i've done them all i've done
shake in the morning shaking the evening
cabbage soup
everything i've done i've done it all
and
they work in the short term
and then
if anything you i've always put on more
weight after that so
doing this for 12 months i've never felt
like i'm
depriving myself of anything because
it's a plan that's tailored absolutely
to you and is a very much a sort of
long-term way to change your health so
you know christmas day this year
i was not on any kind of diet and
normally that would mean for me i just
fall off the truck and i'd say i'm done
then right through till new year's and
then on the 26th i was like right i have
my app out the www app i was looking at
my points thinking all these things and
it's kind of
it really has i would say changed
the way i think about food it's changed
i feel better in my family i've got more
energy i've still got a long way to go
before i get to like a weight that i
would like to be
but it's kind of reassuring knowing that
you're doing something that's working
that if i do this then i'll be
it will work and this is the time of
year to kind of make those changes and
yeah i have to say i've loved this year
i've never felt like i'm on a diet
i'm so glad to hear that because the
best part of the wwe plan is it's not
about a diet i too know personally that
they don't work that it really is about
your lifestyle but i so admire james
that you're sharing the journey with us
most men don't
most men don't talk about it why did you
decide that you wanted to go so public
with it
well
well thanks for saying that that it was
something that was on my mind really
which i i do think
i've often in my life been really
embarrassed to say to people oh i'm i'm
on a diet or no i'm not going to have a
drink today or you know what i mean you
know oh no i won't get the fries i have
a salad or whatever there's some there's
something in society that says that if
you're a man then you don't care what
you look like it's fine and all those
sort of things and i sort of
i this has been a struggle for me as you
know gail i've struggled with my
weight basically my entire life and then
at one point what happens when you're
big
as i've always been you sort of go
well this is who i am
and i'm big and i will be big forever
and i'll be the first person to make a
joke when i enter the room i'll i'll
make those jokes about myself so that no
one else can and all of those things
that come with it and i think there's
lots of men
i know that there's lots of men that
feel that and so because that's what's
kind of an amazing thing about wwe and
being on this app it's like
you can talk to people there's
counsellors there's
chat rooms there's support groups
there's all of these there's wrestlers
all these amazing things and i've i've
i've really had messages with lots of
men who've gone
yeah i've never really felt like i could
be open about the fact that i was
unhappy with the way i look that there's
somehow a vanity in it and really what i
did was go well why don't i make this
about health why don't i make it about
having more energy for my children
having more energy for my family my wife
everything at work everything i do and
so
you look good and i felt like i've never
really seen a man talk about it so
why don't i talk about it and that's
what i've done and i've been really
thrilled with the response i've had from
people actually
thank you for that hey james as much as
i want to ask you about exercise i want
to take advantage of our reflective mood
and look back at your 1 000 episodes of
the late late show and ask you what are
you most proud of when you think about
that body of work
oh man
what do you mean like in it just an in a
specific bit of the
show i mean go in any direction you want
to go with it you look like you've had a
lot of fun james a lot of fun we've been
looking at the clips well i guess that's
yeah thanks guys and also i should say
every time you
show our clips in the morning um
everyone at our in our office is
completely thrilled and we love it and
we we sometimes look at each other and
go look we're on tv
we sort of don't think we're on tv
because we're on in the middle of the
night we never really think we're on tv
we think we're just your leading but um
no we i think look the thing i'm most
proud of is the
is all the people that i work with
really and the things that we've done
and the stuff that i don't know there's
so many things that i've been lucky
enough to do that i sort of feel if that
was a
if that was an auction prize
to
sing penny lane driving down penny lane
in a car with paul mccartney it would go
for
thousands and thousands of dollars and
here i am getting to do it for work you
know there's so many things that i'm
proud of and and i've loved it we like
being your follow-up we like being your
followers love being your after show we
appreciate it thanks for being with us
james corden after show yes we'll be
right back
bye james